[Music]
selena the series just dropped the part
two trailer
and it's going to bitty bitty boom bomb
straight into your heart
i'm so excited for the fans to see
everything fans will recall
part one ended with selena's dad
discovering her relationship with her
guitarist chris perez
you're fired dad you can't fire him dad
we're in love
fast forward to part two and we'll see
their love story unfold and
ultimately their elopement
come on how can you be doing this again
until my husband won't be family and
he'll have to be okay
[Music]
what i'm excited for fans to see in
season two is is the relationship
that forms between uh chris and selena
and how they start to manage becoming
young adults in a relationship
and as selena's star rises we'll see the
strain it puts on her marriage
i'm worried they're gonna split up we're
supposed to lift each other up we both
want what each other wants right
i don't know why you have to keep adding
and adding because what if it stops
what was the secret to you and jesse
coming together and really giving
the the love and importance that that
love story deserves
a lot of communication him and i worked
a lot with each other and had to be very
vulnerable with each other and
trust each other and i trust jesse so
much and really just can't wait for
people
to see his work part two of the series
will
also naturally include lots of music
and performances following selena's
decision to leave the band
and record an album on her own in
english
this time i want to take you solo okay
i haven't had the chance to tell them
yet that if i do the english record they
can't be on it
and we get a glimpse into the series
recreation of selena's iconic 1995
performance at the houston astrodome
in front of nearly 70 000 fans one of
her final shows before her untimely
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
death
you know her stage presence is very
uniquely
selena and people know her for the for
those performances and they
are going to be looking at those details
and i think we really all paid such
close attention to detail
and better grab your tissues because the
series will also cover the end of
selena's life
when you're gone how do you want to be
remembered somebody who wanted to be a
role model
the best daughter best sister the best
friend best wife i just want to be
remembered as
somebody who gave it her all the tejano
superstar was just
23 years old when she was shot and
killed by her fan club president
yolanda saldivar in march 1995.
we have to keep an eye out for her even
when she thinks we don't
no one can do everything alone let me
help in
march et spoke with selena the series
executive producer
and selena's sister suzette quintanilla
she opened up about the challenges of
filming such heartbreaking scenes
i know that there's a lot of difficult
things that you probably don't want to
have to revisit was it emotional for you
getting through season two um
most definitely yeah yeah it's
it's not a walk at the park that's for
sure she's not here
you know and we all know this and it's
just a little bit of everything it makes
you feel happy
and you know there's some sad moments
and then there's some moments that
personally i don't want to revisit you
know and it
and it brings up some really weird
feelings inside so
it's just a little bit of everything to
be honest with you selena the series
part 2
drops may 4th on netflix
you